so I think we're going to run this as a
fireside chat point so I'll be asking
miles here a few questions and I think
also if miles you want to ask me any
questions as well yeah I hope almost
have some time for questions from the
audience and for those of you don't know
i think the wine is open it feel free
thanks so i think the first sort of
question here is obviously miles you've
been with ira one since the very
beginning of our one over many many
years you could maybe talk a little bit
about what was like the beginning very
beginning of starting company I guess
the founding story there sure some of
you may have heard this before so I
apologize if you have but for those that
haven't hire one was created by myself
and some other undergraduates we met at
Yale people imagine we were drinking
buddies but despite my comment earlier
we became drinking buddies after we
started the opening we gave me out of
building a liberal society knew we
wanted to build a company together but
like we had good intersection in terms
of people having different strengths and
weaknesses and we looked at a bunch of
different opportunities to solve
problems in the world wing we kept
coming back to our education our
experience that students as being a real
inspiration for the company we started
in financial services we've expanded the
software and we helped generally
institutions of higher education lower
administrative costs and increase
graduation rates so it's been excited
right god I guess a very beginning will
right now you're chairman were
previously coo how did you feel that
that will change
ty baby starting with you were got you
guys were maybe too d employees or blast
and then a sort of scaled up did you
feel any big changes for yourself
particularly certainly has a lot of
changes he's skilled at different levels
at least a joke that we would start at
the top and work down and I think the
willingness to bring in other management
was something that helps make it
successful to that experienced team
originally you know in sales as a CEO
brought it for ten years those types of
things I think helped scale the business
and grow but it's also my own role I was
a chief operations officer or 13 years
the same title but to that evolved over
time with that means I'll give you an
example part of our service is writing
bank accounts for students ATMs on
campus and so the first I don't know 10
ATMs I was the project manager who is
managing the vendors installed so do
business cash in yourself I didn't
physically go on campus but I was a
project manager coordinating all this
you know might be a thousand miles away
and then I was managing someone who is
doing and managing her manager and
there's a lot of shifts as he'd go
through them it's just one particular
function but I think you'd imagine that
applies to a lot of different things and
I think that is one of the advantages
that I have as a founder I'm not having
experience you know running a 500-person
company but I could rely on the fact
that all of the functions that we could
have done we're doing I had a hand much
earlier on and helping to build a
functioning row with so it does give you
a huge leg up as a founder to sort of
nowhere how will the process were set up
where the cracks are the-- Broadway
stars talking about that earlier you
know sort of a house you used to live in
so Ruth would I menu moving on in
switching gears was debated coo role and
part of the founding management team in
the context of raising money for your
company's I know right now you guys are
a public company but like a lot of
startups she literally started with yes
friends and family type around and they
went through some some institutional
fundraising can you talk a little bit
about what that was like in your role
with doing let's say fundraising at the
entrepreneurial stage so when we were
really early on we're basically
fundraising for the first four years
almost continuously I mean we had some
named rounds but the way it felt
emotionally it was just constant and we
divided up prospect lists and among the
founders we basically you know said you
have these 20 people you have these 30
people so at different times too many
people on my the founding team had more
explicit responsibility for fundraising
but is really something that we were all
doing in the same way presenter earlier
was talked about how everyone your
company becomes a recruiter a certain
periods unimpressed you know the entire
management team was part of the
fundraising process so if you're not
recruiting people you approving funny
faces yeah sometimes think of it you
know the early stage of a business is
you've got to solve that problem getting
investors customers and employees in the
product right and all four would kind of
depend on each other gotta somehow
figure out how you can often make it all
happen got it so I guess the story here
is not the beginning you're always
recruiting people including money
especially the first call four or five
years or so of the business I guess a
lot of drink a lot of the dreams of
entrepreneurs is to one day take the
company public and I know right now
you're chairman of the public company
you talk a little bit about what that
process was like
if my memory serves me correctly I think
guys went public maybe two or three
years ago yes so it took a company
public in 2010 with a traditional IPO
process and fascinating to see how the
sausage is made if any of you were
considering it love to talk to your
client you know learned a lot and there
was there were spaces I wish people had
told us going through the process of
learn a lot and that's partly what I
wanted to do in running a public company
my first love is an earlier stage at
startups that's why I starting
SeeClickFix and that's what I intend to
do in the future are the reason I'm
phasing out my my role in Agra one
excellent and I'd love to hear from your
perspective and you grew a company I'm
sure I here was was on your mind how do
you make a decision to to sell verse /
skill for public offering ESO so quick
background for the people who aren't
familiar mopub was a mobile advertising
than happy we were stand alone now I was
part of Twitter think at the time you
know as you're going through some
fundraising we went through series aids
we should be contemplating insurgency
raised at a time when the Twitter
transaction occurred this was
approximately 23 q4 last year I think
for us that the broader strategic story
was that it made sense but I think Mike
from my personal background having been
investor before I wasn't an operator I
think I kind of got a sense of what it
like to be a public company for me for
me personally inform management
personally and I think as part of that
calculus knowing what it's like crossing
that chasm I think from my perspective
if I was the benevolent dictator of
anything out of the state friday harbor
of network of public that's my personal
cute but that's kind of how
and I think the last question before we
open it up for for Q&A here is I guess
reflecting on on your background rule if
there's a lot of the audience here if
you have maybe one tip or trick that you
want to share with everybody do you have
one off the top of your head broad
question yeah broad question don't
forget to have fun I think mine was you
have to have a good sense of humor
because I think echoing many the
sentiments from from earlier today
they're a lot of ups and downs and thing
that keeps you going through the down
cycle is a young good sense of community
so I mean I think in terms of the key to
success maybe maybe a chance to reflect
on it because I think that the best
teams have short-term pessimism the
larger optimism right to set state what
we're doing is important it is
achievable we can solve this problem
it's worth it but we better fix XYZ
tomorrow Cornell falls apart and if you
can find that within yourself that's
great but at least find that in a
co-founder so that you've got that
attention within the team is it if
you're missing either though the
ingredients you want Faison expenses
excellent so I think with that if we
have a couple minutes left there any
questions in the audience please feel
free to ask
so the question from the gentleman here
was when did you guys have to switch off
quickbooks and put a real finance
package in I think for from ova we were
always with QuickBooks we've always been
on clean books and I will also say that
can't name the names but there are some
they're there to publicly traded
companies right now that I know of in
our space where they didn't switch off
from QuickBooks until literally right
before the IPO and so I guess my my
simple statement related to that for all
the entrepreneurs in the audience for
that specific question it feels like it
to stay on QuickBooks forever until you
go forward if you have a comment I think
this may be getting it just weeds but I
think David's what you want us to do I
think wig books is great up to a certain
number of customers or transactions then
your billing so they can seem to depend
on your type of business right maybe
handles a few thousand of invoices that
you're doing or you know transactions
per month in terms of revenue but if
you're going to get above that you're
going to want at least some kind of
other subsidiary system and then
certainly from a controls perspective
sorry doc static you're referring to it
doesn't cut yes you
so the question is when you go from
keyboard to controller to actual CFO
miles and why I think my perspective on
that is it's going to depend right on
the business what you're doing how much
money you're raising what your baljeet's
going to be like but if you're any of
your starting a business is gonna be
loaning billion dollars he'd probably
better have a pretty to senior finance
person from the very beginning you're
doing business like see click fix I was
doing the accounting in a full time job
and I one saying the counting on
weekends for see click fix for the first
couple years before we got a controller
type and so you know software business
like that with you know dozens of
clients you can go quite a long time you
just outsource bookkeeping or someone
doing it on the side sorry could you
repeat the question that the gentleman
said was what do I think will happen in
the next couple years in the mobile ad
space I don't know for sure because I
can't tell the future but I think the
easiest way to think about it is to look
at what happened on the online desktop
ad space back in my team called 1994
1995 and I'll just spend in 30 seconds
here on this but look back then the big
player today or you please google where
I used to work in Google product is
double click but before Googlebot
double-click it was a standalone company
but how to double-click itself confirmed
we got formed through a series of
acquisitions on desktop space there was
an acquisition of company called that
gravity
ads or a personal desktop space there
are a bunch of other acquisitions as
well and so this story in a sense has
already played out and we kind of if you
define the name game from desktop spaces
today which sure you talk to a lot of
mobile app people or desktop people when
debates this all the time but if you
will get the fax over the last call a
decade and a half the story kind of has
when you played out so using that as a
guide and kind of look at how hey if two
decades ago was the bloom of desktop
today we're arguably little the boom of
mobile kind of use that as a framework
template to view how things are going
forward but in general there's growth I
don't think there's any controversy
about that it feels like the big issue
now is whether people believe
monetization will increase or not I tend
to be a bull this camp but everybody has
different opinions but that's what I'm
saying about that yes
I'll take that one the question was how
many times did you guys almost go
bankrupt before succeeding and guess
what I would say is I can personally
think of at least four times in history
when we were a private company where I
was incredibly stressed out and in that
bowl as CFO at that time yep very
careful you express your stress tube you
don't want to freak out the people out
but I can think of at least four times
when I was very stressed out because in
my mind what you were alluding to was a
serious potential path that we could
walk down so i think that's what i was
able that modesty mmm now one of the
things that was important to us that our
one was open communication and in fact
one of the things that we did was to be
very open about our financials when we
are private company we are actually more
open with employees about our financial
system as a public company which is one
of the great ironies even though we we
strive to still talk about employees but
as a private company we're much more
open with our place value and so plays
new with how close we were getting to
running out of money on number of
occasions a one particular occasion we
were negotiating closing event around
and we had one more thing over the bank
we actually issued pink slips to all of
our employees saying we hope this round
closes and we love for you to continue
working we're just giving you official
notice we only have one more round in 11
payroll or the bank in fact one of our
boys from that time still has his mix
with frames he insisted it was you know
printed on pink paper is very proudly
and today still show it to you if you
guys we didn't slay everyone off at that
was good any other questions in the
audience here
I will we did spend the last like three
thousand dollars in the bank on a party
it wasn't planned that way but it just
turned out there was all any time I was
time for parties it turns out alcohol
reduces I guess stress and anxiety so
good years of capital if anybody is
thinking about that yes so i've been
i've been to talk to y'all for nothing
this is being recorded he's still the
still involved so well you can't talk
about it I'll talk about it and I feel
like I have some context to talk about
this because in a prior career actually
worked in private equity and one of the
pitches as an investment professional
that I would give to a public company
CEO or chairman is basically hey you
know back in two thousand whatever for
example sarbanes-oxley got past and
sarbanes-oxley was passed with a context
of preventing another Enron
unfortunately the amount of regulations
that it puts in place is very
detrimental for example to a private
small company because you stopped to pay
for big public and costs and that's
literally one of those pitches that I
would go up to public company management
and say look this is very painful you
guys know your company other people
don't know it as well maybe it's time to
go private and so speaking from a prior
career in private equity that is one
specific example that resonates with a
lot of public company management miles
can't comment but that's just two things
I'm going to say it seems like there's a
logical one is you know terms of nuts
and bolts of the IPO process and I'll
talk
prolly on impact company so in terms the
IPO process we had a top-tier investment
bank and other its multiple investment
banks from Wall Street and fall ocean
what I thought were you know very
qualified attorneys and I think they
were but one of the things that you know
coming from an Operations background I
thought was really lacking in the IPO
process was a true project manager and
not having been through it before not
knowing when the road map was I couldn't
really play that role but looking back
on it and even during the time is it
whose project managing this like you
know we're setting out virgin requests
and even a small things you know urgent
requests for site notarized documents
from our sales guy who's on the road
when he was at home two days ago asking
if you need to sign anything we had said
no and now we're telling him he has to
run around and find a notary while he's
on the road in you know many up so me
there were a bunch of silly things like
that but there were more important
things that I think had there been a
true project manager I mean we asked
investment bankers they say it's the
lawyers lawyers they wasn't mess maker
lawyers don't really have a discipline a
project management the way I think about
it so that was one two more broadly
impact on our culture i learned to
earlier of one of our values is
communicating openly yeah and being a
public company in particular FD requires
disclosure to the market broadly all the
same time material information you can't
selectively disclose material
information and we took the unusual step
of making all of our employees
considered insiders subject our insider
trading policy therefore in theory gives
us more flexibility to share information
with employees but it's still as a
practical matter has had a chilling
effect on our willingness and ability to
share important information about what's
going
company broadly with a thousand
employees because of the risk of leaves
and selective disclosure which would be
no problem for EM fun so that's meant
there's been less sharing information
that there used to be within the company
and I think that's at a negative impact
on the culture that's something I about
personal and excited about we spent a
lot of time thinking about fourth more
for choosing to go public and putting
steps like that insider policy to
mitigate that but it is still a
significant in fact I think again
summary may be different one difference
between private being private and in
public is being public you're subject to
all types of securities laws that are
good there's reasons why they're there
but from the perspective of being
management or employees of company puts
in a lot of mandated we will static they
normally would not have to deal with
that's a clear difference of the
universe hopefully that addresses your
question and I really fell to the week
or so after going public I went to a
barbecue and someone said I was your
word at work week and I said something I
like a no answer he's like because I'm
an investor so that also really drove it
home to always on the clock great so
we're out of time but i want to thank
miles and John